[Music]
what's the idea what is it what do I
want to be remembered for so I work on
trying to understand the universe I'm a
professor of cosmology that's my job is
to try and understand the universe and
at the moment our best model of the
universe it's a bit of a weird one so
less than 5% of the universe is made up
of the stuff that you and I are made up
off and the rest of the universe is dark
and my job is trying to understand that
now what do I want to be remembered for
do you know what I've got this horrible
fear that by the time I retire we'll
have decided that actually all of this
dark stuff that we currently think is
there isn't actually there and I'll have
wasted my entire career but hopefully
hopefully someone will have discovered
the Dark Matter particle and then I will
be remembered for the very large-scale
maps that I make charting all of this
invisible dark matter all the way across
the universe so at the moment we're
working on a brand new telescope it's on
top of mountaintop in Chile we're going
to be surveying the night sky every
three nights repeatedly over ten years
to build up the deepest map of the
universe and if we can't answer the
question of the dark universe with this
amazing new telescope and survey then I
don't know how I like a challenge I
always have always wanted to challenge
I'm told that I was only six years old
when I asked my primary school teacher
what but the most challenging job in the
world was and she kind of went brain
surgeon or astrophysicist and it wasn't
till I was 18 which decided which those
two paths to take but I went along the
route of astrophysics and and I've loved
it ever since I think science is an
amazing creative
subjects I think that's something that
people don't really appreciate they kind
of think that science is black and white
that there's truth and non-tree that
it's not true science is a it's a broad
spectrum you what other job is there
where you can say I don't know the
answer to this question and I'm gonna go
and find it out to be a scientist it's
like embracing your inner toddler you
can constantly just go why why why and
go and find out the answer and that's
why I love science and I wish more
people get involved in it have I ever
felt frustrated women held back no okay
I've good answer okay so one of the
interesting thing about biases is that
women are just as biased against other
women as men are and so I doubt myself
more than anyone else so I know I don't
think it's unfair that I've been held
back because I also think oh that can't
be right you must triple check that
before you can be absolutely sure so I
think what we need to do to change this
is to really start thinking about what
we're telling our children about you
know how they should view life how they
should view gender because it's really
ingrained in your a very very early
stage so instead of speaking directly to
young girls I'd rather speak to their
mums because I think mums have so much
influence over young girls now when
you're when your children come home from
school with their reading book you sit
down on the couch and they help them
learn how to read and they struggle
because it's hard but you're helped them
through and you know because reading is
really important when they bring home
their science homework you often find
that moms go oh don't worry about that
darling I found that really hard to
don't worry about it and what I want to
say to the moms is I don't you know
don't see that that was said to you and
so you never tried everything's hard at
school you have to work everything
whether it's science maths French
history and all of these things are hard
and we want
children to learn and develop and be
creative and science is just one aspect
of that so mums please don't tell your
children that science is hard and that
not to worry about it help them through
it and and you'll develop and learn too
because science is also really good fun
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you